heather how are you two days after
christmas this year
my husband had emergency surgery and had
a tumor about the size of a baseball
removed from his colon
i'm sorry yeah he was diagnosed
with stage three colon cancer
and we have three children the youngest
is 12
and he is autistic and we are trying to
navigate how much we let him
know about the situation as far as how
dire it is okay because i i don't want
to
wreck his life but i also if
and we are fully expecting a complete
recovery we have no reason to think
that that his debt is not going to
completely recover
sure but he's going to get very sick
when chemo starts in a couple of weeks
and we're just not sure exactly
how much we need to let him know
so give me a number one god bless you
dude i i hate that for you
that's not a christmas anyone needed in
2020 for god's
it sakes and 2020 christmas that let me
just man i know but still that just is
not
great and i'm sorry that happened to you
um how old are your other kids
um 23 and 18. how are they don't laugh
it seemed like a good idea at the time
under the the 23 year old
my daughter has really
stepped up i spent the entire week in
the hospital
with my husband because half the floor
had been turned into a coveted ward and
so they were
extremely short staffed because all they
had to pull their normal staff
to just do covet stuff so she really
what we really tried to do is make it
seem like a big slumber party so we had
friends that sent pizzas
they went to downstairs to my daughter's
apartment and played video games
um and so she is she is handling
things the way she knows how to do which
is
taking care of little details the 18
year old
we get to talk when we go out to walk
the dogs
and he expresses his concerns
in his oblique way right he's
he's managing as well as can be expected
keep i tell you what man you are a saint
and you just help millions and millions
of people across the country with that
one statement
you want to help your late teens early
20s kids deal with
challenges that show up when grandma
grandpa dies when mom and dad get sick
get a dog and take walks every day and
it is the most healing thing yes all of
us don't get to move your body
you get to be in nature you get to have
a relationship and
the same way little kids you play with
them on the floor
you just walk with teenagers and they
don't have to make eye contact with you
but they will slowly start talking to
you
good for you all right so um give me a
quick
rundown what's what's the functioning
level of of your 12 year old
high functioning medium it he
is it's hard to say high functioning or
low functioning because he has his
strengths and his weaknesses
he has very good social skills great he
is a great student he has
anxiety in a way that his brain
misinterprets ordinary signals
misfires and can send them into a panic
attack
which we didn't realize for years an
example was when he was
five and we went trick-or-treating and
the wind was blowing and he
freaked out and was screaming in the
middle of the street that we were all
going to die
right okay so he's got some hyper
sensitivity right
he does okay he does all right so
i 12 years old i'm going to tell you a
story about a guy
he is a good friend of mine his name is
mark charney dr charney
and he is a of all things a
savant he's a theater he's the chair of
the theater and art department and dance
department at a university
and i watched had a ringside seat to
watching him
partner in the one of the most unique
things i've ever seen they partnered
with
the autism center of the university
and what they did was they connected
theater students to
these autistic college students and
the autistic college students some of
them were very high functioning some of
them
were not high functioning socially but
they were very good
right with with fact murmuring facts
some were hypersensitive like the
sensations were
were over alarming right and what they
did was they worked with them and they
put on a play
and what was so magic about the play is
these young kids with autism did not
know how to properly perceive and feel
their own feelings
but they were able to learn this
character
is going to feel like this what does
that look like make me a sad face make
me a happy face
and over the arc of this play it's one
of the hardest i've ever wept watching
theater i'm gonna get choked up here
talking about it
i watch these kids with autism inhabit
other people because they were
inhabiting the facts of these other
people
and part of the facts was learning these
emotions learning these feelings and
learning these pains and then when you
circled back the kids with autism said
i now have a new language for how i feel
and so what i would start with is
and you may say this it may not work
exactly with your kid i think you're
still going to be okay you're not going
to hurt anything
i would go find children's books just go
to amazon
and get three or four children's books
like they would tell a fifth
grader or a sixth grader and there's
going to be a book called mommy got
cancer
where daddy's really sick and the way
kids learn
right is through play and through
literary children's literature like that
and i would buy four or five of those
books and then i would go through them
and see if any of those are going to
identify with your son
and then what i'd have him do is read
them to you and as you read them
i want you to speak out loud imagine
what this would feel like and so what
we're trying to do is to show
him into this story and then you're
going to give him pictures
because the book's going to give you
illustrated pictures
of a dad in a hospital of a mom in a
hospital maybe a dad losing his hair
and he's gonna get a picture of it what
an autistic kid often struggles with is
the outcome
i don't i don't have they don't have the
the
sometimes they haven't learned or they
don't have the capacity to imagine or
picture
and so all the alarms set off at the
same time right
nicely and so what this is going to give
him is a picture of
and it may be if you want to do
something magic it may be a partnership
with your 23 year old kid and your 18
year old kid
and your 12 year old kid that y'all make
up some sort of play
and in your home and you're going to
perform and you can even tell them y'all
have to do this play for me and your dad
and through that it's going to talk
about somebody overcoming something
difficult the play is going to be a
wreck it won't be good everyone will be
dying laughing and crying at the same
time
but it will be a way to bring your
family together and on the back end of
this you'll never forget it
and then through that narrative when you
slowly start to see where
the the your your son's eyes widen
and he goes wow that's the entry way to
have this story
daddy might look like this because
daddy's really sick too
and daddy is one he's gonna get really
skinny also
and you're gonna see the the painful
faces in those books you're gonna see
the smiling faces in the book and the
whole time i want you to never let go of
his hand when you're reading these books
he's not gonna probably realize it but
what you're doing is you are
telling that little oversensitive
amygdala
it's okay and i'm not saying that's
gonna this is gonna heal at all
that's if i have a 12 year old son with
autism that's exactly where i start
and i've seen i saw a profound shift in
a way with
um autistic young men and women that i
had never seen before
i know there's a lot of science autism
scientists that clued in on this
partnership and were all over it from a
research perspective because they saw an
awakening that
they had never seen before but where i'm
starting is with children's literature
through story through narrative and i'm
also giving him that connection because
i'm going to hold his hand through this
entire thing and if we can get 18 year
old brother to sit on his bed on the
other side
that's even better because i want him to
feel surrounded and
safe as we go through this hard hard
place
um let me know how that goes and we will
be thinking about your husband
and um yeah we're going to expect a full
recovery he's going to be better he's
going to get there
and again thank you for being a mom who
loves
loves loves her kids and is doing what
she can to
ask the right questions and walk through
this together and you
heather make sure you got people in your
life that you can lean on because you're
gonna need a place to cry
you're gonna be propping up kids and
dogs and husband
and i want you to have a place where you
can get propped up too
thank you so much for that call